pretty out here you like it yeah
I'm Candace and I am Josh's ex-wife Josh
and I were married for nine years we're
super close he's my best friend I tell
him about my day I tell him I love you
people sometimes think that we're
together
it's important for Josh and I to make
sure that I approve of who he's dating
then I think he will take what I have to
say to Heart
are you fishing right here yeah we'll
try to fish towards that Island sure
whatever
oh this is beautiful sure so left hand's
gonna grip there
and then you're gonna just sidearm it
and then let go of the line As It Gets
right there okay okay I better move
Squad boy careful on that hey
close the bill and then you start
railing until it gets back up here
the logic is to catch a fish but it's
not deep well the fish will come up you
just gotta you gotta reel it in and then
you just keep casting it and how long do
you wait no so this one you cast it and
then you bring it back in until you
catch one
okay
okay it's a stupid thing sit in a desert
and fish
but I'm trying to be open for Josh
let's go up front yeah
that's fine thank you it's cool
so how many dates have you and Josh went
on three or four okay so it's pretty new
yeah but for me strange are you a good
look and you have a son you had the doll
what was wrong
yeah we just decided that we're better
as friends
no I have a boyfriend but Josh and I are
close as you know do you is that a
problem for you no no other girls have
had issues
Josh and I are who we are and we've
always been close and it's Never Gonna
Change
um
I've only met two
but he broke up with them yeah why I
don't know I don't I don't get in this
business like that
yeah
like do we see that I'm totally
different type of person like what kind
of girls he dates
like if he's attractive guy you know but
I'm not his style and it's like kind of
I'm different
you are different from the girls that he
did he usually dates girls that are
younger just a different look
that's all
[Music]